HAL VARIAN: My
name is Hal Varian.
I'm the chief economist
here at Google.
And it's my great pleasure
to introduce my friend
and colleague Glenn
Hubbard, who was named
Dean of Columbia Business
School on July 1, 2004.
So he's been a dean
for nine years.
As a former dean, I can tell
you that's a lot of fortitude.
I'm very impressed.
He's been a Columbia
faculty member since 1988,
and he's the Russell
L. Carson Professor
of Finance and Economics.
He holds A.M. And Ph.D.
degrees in economics
from Harvard University.
In addition to writing more
than 100 scholarly articles
in economics and finance,
he's the author of two leading
textbooks on money
and financial markets,
as well as a author/co-author
of several other books.
And his commentaries appear
frequently in "Business Week,"
the "Wall Street Journal," "New
York Times," "Financial Times,"
"Washington Post" and
several other publications.
In government, Professor Hubbard
served as a Deputy Assistant
Secretary of the US Treasury
Department for tax policy
from 1991 to 1993.
And he was also chairman of the
US Council of Economic Advisers
under President George W. Bush.
So when we invited
him to come out,
I explained that this
was Halloween or nearly
Halloween week.
And I said when you come,
wear an outfit that's
really kind of
different and scary.
And so he said, I know,
I'll wear the outfit
from when I was at
the tax policy group.
And sure enough, it gave
me a start when I saw it.
So, Glenn.
GLENN HUBBARD:
Yeah, apologies in
advance for being
dressed like a banker.
Being before you, I have
a lot of Columbia events
while I am out here.
It's a real treat to get to
talk about "Balance" with you.
And I'll say a bit,
but I am happiest if we
have a conversation about it.
I'll say a little bit about what
the book isn't and what it is,
at the beginning.
What it isn't is yet
another decline-ist screed
from an economist,
historian, political science
about what's wrong with America.
That's not what the book is.
What it is is a
fantastic Christmas gift.
If you want to buy 500 copies,
give it to all your friends,
that that's just terrific.
And I should say
that unless you want
to talk with me about short
term policy issues in Q and A,
this is going to be really
a book about the long view.
I mean, George Bush
once said about me
that Glenn can't even
predict the past.
And I think what he meant by
that was data get revised.
But I'm not going
to sit here and talk
about forecasts over the year.
I'll do whatever
you want in Q and A,
but that not why I'm here.
I wrote the book "Balance"
with a fellow economist
named Tim Kane, because
it helps me go back
to why I became an economist
in the first place.
I was very interested, as I
explain to freshman whenever
I teach freshman economics,
in the following question.
Why isn't the whole world rich?
It sounds like a
simple question.
It's actually devilishly hard.
We know there are enormous gaps
over time and place in wealth.
And where do those come from?
And in a lot of my own
work as an economist,
like many economists I've tried
to focus on sources of growth.
What ignites prosperity?
This book has a
slightly different take.
It's the mirror, the
flip side of that.
It's about what happens
when growth stops.
Basically, we know we have
episodes where economies
grow for very long periods of
time and become great powers.
And then that growth either
decelerates sharply or stops.
And what do we know about that?
What do economists have to
say about great power decline?
Now I come at this
from two perspectives.
One is history, and I'll
say a little bit about that.
But what I'll talk a
little bit more about
is the contemporary
United States,
because this is obviously
a topic that's on the mind,
not just of economists
but policymakers and many
average folks in our country,
of where we're heading
and what growth is likely to be.
And to start and frame
the idea with you,
let's suppose that rather
then sitting here today,
we were getting together
about 100 years ago.
So it's 1913, and we're on the
eve of the first World War.
And if you want to look at
what per capita income was
in industrial countries
in today's dollars,
that would've been typically
about $3,000 in 1913.
That number is obviously
much higher today,
which tells you
about growth we've
experienced in the past century.
If you were lucky enough to
be an American or a Brit,
that $3,000 number
was about $4,000.
Now let's turn the clock back.
So it's not 1913 anymore.
It's year 1,000
in the Common Era.
If you were to look at
the same numbers-- again,
today's dollars, so we're
comparing apples to apples--
that number would
have been about $400,
which tells you again
there was growth
in the intervening period.
But here's where I
want to start with you.
Let's turn the clock way back.
So not to 1913, and not to
the year 1000, but to Rome
at the time of Caesar Augustus.
In that period in
Rome, the prosperity
in the core areas of what
was then the Roman Empire
was actually greater than the
prosperity 1,000 years after.
Now that's kind of
hard to understand,
because typically
we think that there
can be slowdowns in growth,
slowdowns in productivity,
maybe slowdowns in technology.
But that kind of absolute
regress on a very grand scale
for a very long period of time
can be hard to understand.
Now this is a familiar topic.
And indeed Paul Kennedy, who
is a very famous historian,
wrote a book-- some
of you may have
seen it-- about 25 years
ago called "The Rise
and Decline of Great Powers."
And Kennedy had in
mind, connecting
essentially the same
points I'm going
to try to connect with you.
What happened to Rome?
And what might happen
to America today?
And in Kennedy's view, if you
looked at great power decline,
whether that was Ancient Rome,
the British Empire, which
would have been the
most recent preeminent
power before America,
and America today.
It was all about
military overstretch.
So Kennedy had this very, very
elaborate overstretch thesis.
And indeed what caught
me about his book,
and the reason I was somewhat
skeptical as an economist,
was the cover.
So if you look at the cover of
Kennedy's book, it's a globe.
And it has stairs that are
going up and down the globe.
And if you look at who
is has tripped and fallen
almost to the floor,
it's John Bull,
who's the symbol of
the United Kingdom.
Already starting to
stumble a little bit,
but not having fallen
all the way down,
is Uncle Sam, symbol
of the United States.
Who do you suppose is rising
up the stairs very confidently?
Now keep in mind, I
told you this book
was written 25 years ago.
A Japanese salary man.
Right?
So coming up the stairs, this
view that Japan was necessarily
going to eat the lunch
of other countries.
And many economists at the
time, including myself,
were a little skeptical
of that, because it's
one thing to have a growth
catch up to the frontier.
It's quite another to
shift the frontier.
And query-- was the Japanese
model set up for that?
Now it's not just
Kennedy and historians
that were looking maybe
through a different lens
at economic power.
No less an economic lion
than Paul Samuelson, himself,
in his very famous and
bestselling "Principles
of Economics" boo-- had
for many, many editions
a date at which the Soviet
Union's economy would
overtake the United States.
Now what was interesting
was with each edition,
the date kept moving out,
And on or around 1989,
the reference got dropped.
So it's not just
historians, it's someone who
is as great and as smart
as Paul Samuelson was,
essentially falls
into the same thing.
But one of the places where
Tim and I start the book
is with a fundamental
question of what
does it mean to
have economic power?
What does that mean?
As an economist,
not as a politician.
And we argue that leaders,
many times in history,
have been confused about
the sources of wealth
and economic power.
And in some cases,
interest groups
are not confused that
all, but simply managed
to redistribute
resources to themselves.
To make it simple, because
this is a book written
for popular consumption,
not for economists,
we go back to the intuition of
what I would call three great S
economists-- Smith, and
Solo and Schumpater.
So in Smith, I think
about the scale or size
of an economy,
what we today would
call GDP or something like that.
Solo's views about investment
and future orientation ,
and of course the Shumpaterian
view of the frontier
and the process that would
generate innovation that moves
the frontier.
All of those a sources
are economic power.
In the book we
actually developed--
it's sort of a trivial point.
If you're interested,
it's there-- kind
of index of economic power
looking across place and time,
using the Penn World data.
The United States is definitely
by almost any such measure
the preeminent economic power.
I don't think that's
controversial.
What I'm about to say is a
little more controversial.
We think it's likely to remain
in the preeminent economic
power for a considerable
period of time.
One of the countries that's
often talked about today,
much as the Japanese salary
men in Paul Kennedy's example,
is, of course, China.
China is growing very
rapidly, as often
happens in pronounced
catch-up phases.
It's very difficult
though to pivot
from that to
frontier-producing growth,
particularly in an economy
whose financial system, whose
rule of law, is not
oriented toward that.
So we can come back
to this if you like,
but Tim and I would
count ourselves
among the skeptics
of China immediately
overtaking United States
in economic power.
So let's have a look at Rome.
Kennedy's thesis,
again, was that Rome
spent too much on its military.
It was too adventuresome.
Now, like all stories, there
is an element of truth to that.
We argue that what really
killed Rome was understretch.
We point to a series of
examples in the book,
starting from the famous
Hadrian's Wall with the idea
of walling in Rome
to stop immigration--
does this sound familiar in
current policy debates?--
debasing its currency,
pursuing policies that favored
the present over the future,
including fiscal policy
and what would be the
equivalent of monetary policy.
Rome's understretch over a
period of time led to its rot
far more than its
military adventure.
And this is a pattern
you actually see
with many great
power declines, just
to give you a quick
tour of [INAUDIBLE].
I really want to focus
mainly on America today,
but we have a look
at Ming, China,
for example, which was in
its day, the commercial envy
of the world.
Virtually every
school kid learns
of the voyages of
Cheng Ho, at least
in the transliteration
of my schoolboy days.
And those voyages were to
establish the great merchant
class of China with shipping.
The only problem,
of course, much
like a predatory guard in
Rome, usurped power for itself,
people surrounding the emperor
were not too fond of the fact
that merchants and
shipping folks were gaining
political and economic
power in the country,
and eventually persuade
the emperor not only
to decrease that
commercial activity.
But literally burn the ships.
Growth stops.
Regress happens.
Not because the Chinese
forgot how to build ships
or forgot how to do commerce.
But because of a
political institution
couldn't keep up with the
economic changes facing China.
Another case study we
look at is imperial Spain.
Oftentimes, when
we hear the phrase
"the sun will never
set," people commonly
think of that as being a story
about the British Empire.
The quote is
actually about Spain.
Spain in its day was
the preeminent empire.
But Spanish leaders
were very confused
about what economic power
is and where it came from.
They thought it was
gold and silver.
The mercantile policies
pursued by Spain
were toward the advancement
of gold and silver,
and not toward the
kinds of commerce
an innovation that would
lead to true growth.
Spain also pursued a very
present-oriented policy,
defaulting many
times on its debt.
And an empire that
at its height seem
to span the world
simply rotted away.
We look at the case
of the Ottoman Empire,
which every school
kid is taught--
that was the sick man of Europe.
Not really true.
If you look at the origins
of the Ottoman Empire,
it was an administrative marble.
Much like the Praetorian
guards of Rome,
or the court units rounding
the emperor in China,
there were a group
called janissaries
that were slaves who
rose to be leaders.
The Grand Vizier, himself,
was always from this core.
And they were an
administrative marvel,
until they decided that the
technological developments
happening threaten their power
base vis-a-vis the sultan.
And, again, much has
happened in imperial China
or imperial Rome killed it off.
Just to mention a few other
case studies we look at,
we look at the
British Empire, which
seems to be the archetype
for Kennedy's case.
After all, World War
I and World War II
were exhausting for Britain,
particularly because it
was having to defend an
empire all over the world.
But we argue that part of
the seeds of British problems
went back to an incident
on or around 1776,
involving the United
States, where Britain
was insufficiently British,
with folks outside of Britain.
That lack of outwardness,
even though inside Britain
was a classic
liberal open policy,
the British did not follow
that policy in their colonies.
The most celebrated
example of that failures
is the United States.
But it happened many times
in the British colonial
experience.
We look at Japan after
the war through the lens
of the game of Go, which is
a very hard game to play.
The beginning of Go--
it's a board game.
Almost anything is possible.
At the end, the conclusion
is certainly known.
In the middle is where
life is interesting.
And we argue in the
book that that's really
what Japan pursued is
the arc during the war
like I'm after the war, the
growth and catch up phase
was very, very impressive
But his stalled out,
relative to the
American frontier,
in the past two decades.
A part of that is from
bad macroeconomic policy.
But part of that are from real
structural barriers and failure
to understand economic power.
We also look at the Eurozone.
And one other example,
I will mention,
is the state of California.
As a New Yorker,
I sometimes think
of California as a foreign
country, and I group it
in with the other examples.
But California is
interesting because it
is the only part of the world,
outside of the Mediterranean,
that has the climate--
the wonderful climate--
of the Mediterranean.
It's the only large
land mass that has that.
It, however, shares
something else
with the Mediterranean, which
is a political system that
can look fairly dysfunctional.
And the Praetorian guards
that I talked about from Rome
are reconstituted in California
i a variety of interest groups,
including public workers unions.
So in each of these cases,
a fantastically successful
rich society is held back
from where it might be.
Now I want to talk about the
contemporary United States.
And I have this sort of
historical build-up with you
to now pivot a little
bit to economics,
because I think there's a view
many people have, particularly
many people in my profession,
in economics, that what's
facing the nation are a
series of technical problems.
So, for example, I'm going
to talk with you about debt.
How do we devise
technical solutions?
In none of the
historical cases--
and certainly, I
will argue with you
not in what faces American
today-- is the problem
a lack of economic knowledge.
It is not a lack of
technical issues.
There are plenty of smart
economists, business people,
policymakers on both
sides of the aisle.
Rather the point, as in each
of the historical case studies,
is that the political
rules of the game
don't facilitate that
technical solution.
Now let me do a build
up and be more specific.
So in the US, one
of the key examples
we've seen in the recent
weeks is the battle
over the future of
debt in the country.
So we all know we've
had politicians
playing with matches in the
capital and the White House.
And part of this
is-- well, maybe
it's political theater
or short-term gain,
Democrats versus Republicans.
It's actually a more
fundamental structural problem.
What has happened in
the country, and much
of the industrial world
also, particularly
in Europe and Japan, is
the very large run-up
in central government
debt relative to GDP.
This is a real problem.
There was a debate around the
publication of Carmen Reinhart
and Ken Rogoff's
book "This Time is
Different" about whether
there exists a tipping point
that if a debt to GDP ratio
gets at a particular level,
bad things happen.
I don't think any economist
can honestly tell you
there's a number.
I can't tell you that at 80%
or 90% or you pick your number,
bad things happen.
But I can tell you
a bit of arithmetic,
that by definition this
rising debt to GDP ratio
will cause higher tax
burdens in the future
and will cause spending
adjustments on much of what
the public thinks government
does-- defend the country,
educate children,
conduct basic research.
We've seen this experiment run
in many industrial economies
that simply can't project
themselves in the way
that fast growth
economies used to be.
Now, to understand why this
isn't a technical problem,
a little bit of
history is in order.
So let's do an
experiment together.
Suppose I asked you
go back to the time
of the American Revolution.
And then go to 1970, and
tell me about the shape
of the federal
debt to GDP ratio.
Not the numbers, just the
shape-- up, down, flat?
Anybody?
Any conjectures
what it looks like?
Revolution to 1970.
AUDIENCE: It goes up during war.
GLENN HUBBARD: Exactly.
It's entirely a story
of war and peace.
If you look at every
major debt buildup
episode in the country--
and by the way,
I could have said
Britain or France to you.
It's true of most
industrial countries.
We build up debt in war.
We're borrowing to finance
the war, which is actually
good fiscal policy to do.
And after a war, we stop
spending so much and we grow.
So both the numerator and the
denominator are kicking in.
To give you just a
quick example of that,
at the close of World War II,
America's debt to GDP ratio
was in excess of 100%.
That number was 40% by 1960.
Just stopping the
military spending
and rapid postwar growth
brought it back into line.
Now take that same experiment.
So we talked about
the Revolution
to the time of say 1970.
Now let's for any industrial
country look at 1970
to the present.
Any difference in what
the picture looks like?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
GLENN HUBBARD: Yeah,
basically, first
of all, mechanically
what's happening
is there are a few
hills and valleys
but they're small, relative
to the war and peace years.
And it sort of goes straight up.
Now it's really
not Kennedy's view.
For example, I'm not a
foreign policy expert
so I can't tell you
whether America's
military interventions
in the past decade or so
have been wise or unwise.
But I can tell you, as a bean
counter or as an economist,
they're not the problem.
So military spending
has fallen sharply
as a share of the economy
decade after decade,
following the Second World War.
The current debate
in the country
is really whether military
spending ought to be 3% of GDP
or maybe 4% of GDP.
But that's the gating.
The entitlement programs,
the social welfare programs,
particularly Social Security and
Medicare are much, much larger.
And what we've seen since
the late '60s, early '70s,
is an explosion in
growth in these programs.
So if you look at shares
of GDP and components
of federal spending,
most of what--
if you went and polled
people on the street and say,
what does government do?
Defense, education,
what goes in Washington
as "discretionary
spending"-- that's
all sharply down
relative to GDP.
What has gone up
many, many fold is
Medicare and Social Security.
So Medicare is about
1% of GDP in 1970.
It's about 6% and rising.
With Social Security
and Medicare
together, the
Congressional Budget Office
tells us just 20 years from now,
if we don't make any changes,
we'll spend about 10 percentage
points of American GDP
more on just those two
programs than we do today.
And if the whole tax share in
GDP, even in the best of times
is a number like
18%, 19%, I think
you can see the
scale of the problem.
Now here's the rub.
What I've said so
far is just facts.
And I don't think serious
people dispute those facts.
But I think the
general consensus
is we just haven't found the
right technical solution.
Nobody's come up
with the right way
either to change those
programs or raise taxes or cut
something else.
You can do the arithmetic in
your head on what's needed.
I don't think that's accurate.
There are plenty
of ways to restore
long-term fiscal balance.
The levers are familiar.
They involve program changes,
other spending changes,
tax increases, or the
promotion of growth.
And 100 policies fall into
those combined buckets.
So that's not really the issue.
Rather I think we've got
to learn from three things.
One is this classic
economist joke.
The second is the
game of basketball.
And the third is the
book "The Odyssey."
Now the classic economist
joke always troubles me,
because I am the
classic economist.
And you've probably all heard
the classic economist joke,
but I'll repeat it
to make my point.
So you have a chemist
and a physicist
and a economist who are
marooned on a desert island.
And a can of soup or
stew washes ashore.
And the physicist says, let's
beat it open and we'll eat it.
The chemist says, no,
that's a little bit messy.
Why don't we heat it?
It will open, and we'll eat
it and it'll be warm to boot.
And the economist says--
AUDIENCE: Assume a can opener.
GLENN HUBBARD:
Assume a can opener.
That's the painful
joke for economists.
Now the problem with
what we're looking
at in the current
situation is we're
assuming a good government.
We're assuming the
political process
can deliver the right outcome.
We simply haven't put in
the right technical inputs.
That was not true in any of
the historical case studies.
Nor I would argue is it true for
the contemporary United States.
And here's where
basketball comes in.
So in the 1930s, the game
of basketball, obviously
a very popular
sport, nearly died
as a sport of great
spectator interest.
And the reason, if you go
back to books at that time,
was what was called
the Tall Man Problem.
Now this was a
period in which there
was no shot clock in basketball.
There was no three-point shots.
So the game looked a little
different than today.
And what would happen is if you
were the team with the tallest
guys, they could simply
hang around the hoop
and dominate play.
Now that's great if you're
the team with the "tall men."
It's not so much fun to watch,
and the sport was in trouble.
Now enter a man
named Howard Hobson.
Howard Hobson was
the basketball coach
of the University of Oregon.
He comes to my attention
because he's actually
writing a Ph.D.
Thesis at Columbia.
Now we know this was an era
where basketball coaches got
Ph.Ds at Columbia and
other institutions.
And his Ph.D. thesis is a book
called "Scientific Basketball"
which I recommend to any of
you, where he makes consciously
the argument for a
three-point shot.
Eventually, there's
an experimental game
between Colombia and
Fordham in the mid-1940s.
Columbia wins.
Over time, Hobson's idea works
its way into college ball,
eventually to pro ball.
And of course, a much
more familiar name,
Michael Jordan can trace his
success back to this man.
I raise this point with you
for a simple illustration.
Sometimes, whether
you're talking
about a very successful society
or a very successful game,
when there's an adaptation,
you have to change the rules.
So if we can't assume
a good government,
and a byproduct
of that is we may
think we need to
change the rules,
what would that rule change be?
Well, here's the story from
"The Odyssey" that I love.
It's the story of the Sirens.
So in the story of the Sirens,
it's a story of temptation.
It's a story of
leadership and of joy.
In the story of
course, our leader
has the men put wax
in their ears and row.
Remember the Sirens have
this beautiful music, very
physically appealing.
The only problem is if
you follow their way,
let's just say bad
things happen to you.
And so what our
leader wants to do
is have the men row past
with wax in their ears.
But he wants the benefit
of the Siren song.
How does he get it?
AUDIENCE: Lashes
himself to the mast.
GLENN HUBBARD: He lashes
He's able to get the benefit
because he has absolutely
had to change the rules to
constrain his own behavior.
Now if you go back
to the debt dynamic
in industrial countries for
the moment that I started with,
we know we don't have a
self-correcting mechanism.
Before, we had war and
peace, which were essentially
self-correcting
budget mechanisms.
And much of the rules we
have around the budget
from the founders on were
written with that in mind.
So, for example,
what we fight over
in the past couple of
weeks, the so-called debt
limit negotiations.
The debt limit comes
out of World War I.
It's an idea that
before World War I,
the Congress had to vote
literally on every bond issue.
And the idea was that since
things were self-correcting,
why not have these periodic
allowances for borrowing--
i.e., when you're
fighting a war,
because that's what borrowing
meant in those days.
And it would allow the Congress
not to constantly do this.
Now, of course, that works if
you have a natural adjustment
where debt comes down
at some subsequent date.
But as I told you,
that is not what's
happening, not
only in the US, but
in other industrial countries.
And we may need to think
about changing the rules.
Tim and I offer a couple
of potential rule changes.
One which I would call a light
rope, in "The Odyssey" example,
would be to take
the programs that
are at issue, which are these
big social insurance programs,
and treat the accounting
much more like you
would in a business.
And so in a business, if
I decide to promise people
more in the future on
something or there's
a change in accrued
liabilities, that's
not something
that's in the ether.
It shows up in my
financial statements today.
And it has to be accounted
for and paid for.
So one could say to
the Congress, look,
it's not that
everything is on budget,
but the change in the accrued
liabilities of these programs
is an expense.
You'll put it on the budget.
And you have to go to the
American people and say,
we'd like to raise
taxes to pay for this,
or we'd like to cut some
other spending-- you pick
how to pay for it-- or maybe
we'll reform those programs.
But force the choice to be made.
Tim and I argue at
the present time,
we have a kind of political
prisoner's dilemma game,
where if one party
simply wants lower taxes
and another party
wants high spending,
with the current
budget rules, there's
an unfortunate equilibrium.
It's just called
debt accumulation.
Both parties can
get what they want,
but ultimately, of
course, that's not stable.
There is a tighter
binding of rope.
And it's a spending limitation.
Now in the book, we argue, as
I think most economists do,
that literal balanced budget
amendments of the types that
have been considered are
fundamentally flawed.
They are hard to
implement particularly
around business cycles.
You don't want the government
exacerbating a business cycle.
But it doesn't mean that
you can't design something.
We put out a simple example.
There are many, many others.
You can imagine a
spending limitation
that says government
spending as a share of GDP
is limited to the moving
average of some number of years.
The example we
use is seven years
of inflation-adjusted revenue.
Getting rid of the
inflation effect.
I pick seven, because it's
the number in Pharaoh's dream.
But if you like
six, eight, ten, it
doesn't matter-- some
long period of time.
That's the way typically
most endowments, for example,
work in a university or
any large philanthropic
organization.
And we would allow the
Congress to deviate
from that whenever
it wants, but only
with escalating super majorities
every time it deviates.
And note the difference
in this kind of approach
from what's often discussed.
First of all, it's a
long period of time.
You don't have the
cyclical problem.
We also don't have a
bias as to economists
as to whether the solution
is raising taxes or cutting
spending.
I think that's a
political choice,
and the American
people have every right
to make that choice,
as long as they
know that one of those or some
combination is the choice.
So we think this kind of a rule
change may help a great deal.
But just to kind of
close where I began,
I see that we're
in this discussion
at a kind of fork in the road.
And you can see the fork
in the road going back
to the historical case
studies, where they're
about Kennedy and military,
or about what we're
talking about in the
intersection of politics
and economics.
And I would like you
to imagine behind me
as if there were two
pictures to illustrate this.
One is Agatha Christie, and
the other's Ben Franklin.
Now Agatha Christie is one
of my favorite writers.
I like murder mysteries.
I like stories that
happen in exotic places,
involving posh guests.
That's a typical Agatha
Christie murder mystery.
An example that I would use to
illustrate this is the story
"And Then There Were None."
s Then There Were None," like
a typical Christie story,
starts with a dinner
party in a mansion
with a group of posh forks,
and then a murder happens.
And it actually puts
kind of a damper
on the evening
when that happens.
But pretty soon, people come
back to the dinner party
and enjoying themselves,
except there's another murder.
And you can see, given
the title of the book,
where this is headed.
And then there were none.
Now what's interesting to me
about this-- the economics
of great power failure and the
economics of growth stoppages,
they tend to look like
"And Then There Were None."
It's not some single act
of military overreach.
Rather, it's a series
of political mistakes,
of missing something in
the economic environment,
and failing to act
until there are none.
An alternative view, in
this fork in the road,
a more optimistic view,
is actually Franklin's.
One of my favorite
quotes from Ben Franklin
is his looking, at the
Constitutional Convention,
at the chair in which George
Washington sat the whole time
as the leader of the convention.
And carved in the back of that
chair that Washington sat in
was a sun.
And Franklin said he spent the
whole time-- presumably not
the whole time, but much
of the time-- wondering
whether the sun was rising or
setting and concluding it's
rising.
If you go through all these
historical case studies,
they're cautionary tales, I
would argue, but only that.
There is nothing written
into the detail of history
that suggests a great
power has to fail.
There is, however, a road map
of how that failure occurs.
And that's the cautionary tale.
That's the theme of "Balance."
You'll see on the cover pictures
of ancient Rome and America
that try to tie it together.
So I'll stop there.
But I'd be delighted
to take any questions.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So Gordon Crovitz in this
week's "Wall Street Journal"
talked about running
experiments on policies.
And he said Silicon
Valley runs experiments.
And it's true, right?
Most of your web use
actually runs experiments.
And you propose
some rule changes,
and we could run experiments to
go try to deploy those changes.
But I don't understand how
you would deploy these changes
or run an experiment
to see which rules
are the right one, because the
time frame where I go figure
out whether that's
a good rule is long.
And secondly, it's hard to
go measure the impact, right?
How do I measure these things?
Do I go by a bunch of
academics and policy wonks,
and they all
disagree at the end.
So can we run experiments
to go and try out
these rules in various places?
And if so, how would we do that?
GLENN HUBBARD: It's
a great question.
I would argue that there's
two kinds of experiments,
to use your term,
that we can look at.
One are the roles of state
rule changes over many decades,
because states do have
much more limits on budgets
and have experimented over
many years with a variety
of spending limitations, capital
and current budgets and so on.
And there's a large
literature that's
learned a great deal
about budget balance.
There are also two
national case studies
within the past
couple of decades--
one is Canada and the
other's Sweden-- where
these sorts of budget issues led
to fundamental process reforms
to right the fiscal ship.
So our book isn't so much
a book about solutions.
There are lots of
different ways to do it.
But the idea is
that you really have
to experiment with rule changes.
The notion that we could wait
for a leader on a white horse
of either party, or just hope
that some smart economist
shows up.
We just think that's naive.
But your question's spot on.
It's very hard.
AUDIENCE: So I think,
continuing on that vein,
you've essentially proposed
a technical solution
to the current issues
that we're facing.
But as you mentioned in your
talk, a lot of these issues
are borne from political
problems, rather than
a lack of technical solutions.
So how would you go
about, for example,
changing the rules
of the game, when
the political parties or the
political actors involved
are clearly-- it's clearly
in their best interest
to keep the system as it is.
GLENN HUBBARD: It's
a great question.
And I would argue we haven't
proposed a technical solution,
because I said we're
agnostic as to what
form these limitations take.
The right would have one
view, the left another.
We're outlining a
family of rules.
But I would say a
couple of things.
One is that we need to have
much more political process
competition.
One thing I didn't mention,
but we talk about in the book,
is some unwitting implications
of campaign finance reform
in the US over the
past several decades
have led to monopoly powers
of two political parties
in the process sort of
ossifying competition,
making it very difficult
to have new budget ideas.
We can break that.
The other is the prospect for
spending limitations are not
as grim as they might appear.
34 states have
considered and passed
spending limitations
for the federal level
in the past two decades.
And twice in that period, one
house of Congress passed it.
So remember, there are two
roots to amendments-- Congress
or states.
Both of those have
been fairly active,
so I think this is a
topic of conversation.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned
that the entitlement
is the main driver
for the debt going up.
But I assume the entitlement
is to offset inequality.
But in the meantime,
inequality still is widening.
So my question is to
solve this problem,
do you think it's a
technical solution
or we need a sort of
political process for that.
GLENN HUBBARD: Well,
I think that you've
mixed a couple of
interesting questions.
in there.
I don't know that it's
the case, empirically,
that the entitlement
programs are
helping on the inequality front.
For example,
wealthier people tend
to live longer and have higher
medical expenditures in old age
for a variety of reasons.
These programs may even
slightly at the margin,
even though they were designed
with the best of intentions,
not be helping so much.
Policies to go at
inequality, I don't think
are so much policies
about entitlements
as they are policies about
education and training.
So I think there are
ways to get at that
without the entitlements.
One thing that the US could
do that would radically
lower its entitlement
burdens-- and this
is a technical
solution-- would be
to turn them into
safety net programs.
So they would be
focused on inequality.
They would be very strong safety
nets for low income Americans,
but essentially not part of the
life of middle and upper income
Americans.
That would be a very different
world than the one we live in.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned
accounting systems
for government spending
and liabilities.
What examples around
the world do you
know that use general
accounting practices
or something comparable to that.
And do they do better?
GLENN HUBBARD: We certainly
don't have too many examples
of governments having the
same kind of transparency
as the private sector.
But the two reforms I
mentioned in Canada and Sweden
are probably the closest
at really being transparent
about social welfare obligations
and the present value
of those obligations.
And they were borne in a crisis.
One reason I think one has
to be worried about the US
is while Canada and Sweden
did make these changes,
they were made in an environment
where they absolutely had to.
They couldn't borrow money.
One of the issues
in Washington today
is whenever economists like
me show up and ring the alarm
bell, they say, but look
at low interest rates are.
We can borrow the money.
So it becomes hard to do.
We have the examples,
but unfortunately there
are not many examples of
change made voluntarily
as opposed to hitting the wall.
AUDIENCE: So we don't have any
examples at the state or county
levels that have implemented
this that you're aware of--
or city?
GLENN HUBBARD: Oh,
we certainly do.
Yes, there is a state
literature on variance
in pension accounting.
States have very
different rules in that.
One of the things we argue in
the book that I didn't mention
is while the federal
government can't legally
tell states what to
do in their budget,
the municipal bond tax exemption
is not in the Constitution.
It's a creature of law.
And so one could
say, if you want
to borrow in the
tax-exempt market,
you will conform to
these accounting--
so actually, there's
quite a bit of leverage
the federal government
has over states that's
so far not been exported.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks for the talk.
To what extent do you
think the structure
of our monetary system impacts
your thesis about our abilities
to either drive up and borrow
beyond what we otherwise would?
You mentioned, for example,
that every time an economist
comes up and raises
the alarm, people
point to how low
interest rates are.
GLENN HUBBARD:
Well, it's certainly
the case that current
US monetary policy has
kept interest rates very low.
I think in the advent
of the financial crisis
or right after the financial
crisis, that was wise,
particularly keeping spreads
between mortgage-backed
securities and treasuries low.
For what it's
worth, I don't think
there's much evidence to suggest
that lower long-term interest
rates, as a result of
quantitative easing,
have had a large material
effect on the real economy.
They certainly have had
an effect on asset prices,
but not a very big effect
on the real economy.
I know some argue the fed
is enabling Washington.
I don't think that's
the fed's intent.
But it's certainly
a consequence.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I'm not
clear on what you
think was the cause of the
shift from war and peace cycles
in the debt to
ever-increasing debt.
Where did that come from.
GLENN HUBBARD: It's the
structure of the entitlements.
So basically in the
mid-'60s is the introduction
of the Medicare and
Medicaid programs.
And it's in 1972 that when
Wilbur Mills, who was then
Chairman of the Ways
and Means Committee,
before he cavorted
with a stripper and got
thrown out of Washington,
he had a policy
of double-indexing
Social Security benefits,
so the real value of those
obligations rose sharply.
So in a period from between,
say, mid 1960s to mid 1970s,
we had enormous
structural change
in those programs, none of which
were recorded on the budget.
I mean, the liabilities part.
The current year spending
is, but the accruing
of those liabilities
wasn't recorded at all.
So it is almost a-- it's not
a literal natural experiment
but a sea change in policy.
AUDIENCE: I was curious-- I
think my intent was really
in regards to both
the dollar statuses,
the global kind of
financial reserve currency,
and the use of federal
debt as the primary asset
under a standard banking rules.
So, for example, treasury
bills are your unit
of account for reserve
requirements for everything.
And they're just kind of
a basic building block
that you assume everything
has to operate on.
GLENN HUBBARD: Basically, the
US gets an enormous benefit
from what Charles
de Gaulle called
years ago "an
exorbitant privilege"
that we have the
reserve currency
countries from all
over the world.
People are willing to
hold pieces of paper
with Ben Franklin's picture.
Or they're willing to hold
dollar-denominated assets.
So it's a little bit odd when
politicians in Washington
trifle with the full
faith and credit of the US
because it is an
enormous positive impact.
So from a macro perspective,
that's very valuable.
It's also the case
that we do sometimes
get distortions in
the financial system
from financial repression.
I'm not sure if that's where
your question was headed.
By telling financial
institutions
they need to hold a certain
category of instruments
as riskless, may distort
portfolio holdings.
And we certainly are doing
that in contemporary bank
regulations.
A lot of financial
repression that
has happened since the close
of the financial crisis
there would have been a
time, say, a couple of years
ago, if you were a large bank
holding Greek bonds-- would
have been riskless.
Lending to a main
corporate credit in the US
would have required a
great deal of capital.
Seems a little odd.
OK?
Thank you very much.